so some old some old tweets from Cory
Booker have been as they say unearthed a
woman named Anna Fitzpatrick on Twitter
found them and apparently Cory Booker
has been has been recycling the same
joke for for like ten years in a row but
but it's this is a great joke guys this
is this is killer material Cory Booker
is one of the I didn't realize this he's
one of the comedy icons of our time so
let me just hear are the jokes in 2009
he tweeted sleep and I broke up a few
nights ago I'm dating coffee now she's
hot that's good it's good then again in
2009 he tweeted had another fight with
sleep last night I left her and I'm
hanging out with my smoldering love
coffee now and tonight she's smoking hot
then 2010 he tweeted sleep and I broke
up again tonight I'm finding comfort
with my new special friend coffee she's
hot oh man this is good stuff then in
2010 he tweeted me no sleep left me for
another dude I'm with coffee now she's
got a stimulating attitude well that was
a rhyme too did you get that then in
2011 sleep and I are fighting again so
I'm hanging out with my old love coffee
she's so hot
[Laughter]
2012 sleep and I have irreconcilable
differences we separated I'm dating my
tall hot sweet new friend coffee
2012 again had a fight with sleep
she's so uncooperative I'm hanging with
coffee now she's so sweet and very hot
so like is he getting as a hot as in
temperature wise but also attractive you
know like the way they 2012 yet again
sleep and I broke up tonight I'm now
dating coffee
she's 2013 sleep and I broke up again
I'm back with coffee she is she's hot
she said the coffee's hot did you
2015 sleep and I broke up I'm dating
coffee now she's 2017 I broke up with
sleep last night and I'm dating coffee
this morning I appreciate her warmth and
stimulating company stimulating this is
a BB oh man that is a classic classic
stuff
I think Cory Booker might have a
condition actually I'm kind of worried
about him someone should probably check
on him all right before we before we go
on it was a lot to talk about today and
I think it's enough comedy for now we
all need to just settle down here for a
moment and before we move on let's check
in with light stream I'll begin just by
asking you this have you actually looked
at the interest rate on your credit card
I know sometimes you you don't want to
look at it because it's it's too
horrific to do that but it is a the fact
remains that the average interest rate
on a credit card can be over 18 percent
APR all right 18 percent which is
horrifying news but here's the good news
you can refinance your high interest
credit card balances and save with a
credit card consolidation loan from
light stream remember that 18 percent
APR that we just talked about well you
can get a rate as low as six point one
four percent APR with auto pay and the
rate is fixed it will never go up so you
have that that confidence if you want to
save you even more my listeners get an
additional interest rate discount the
only way to get this discounts is to go
to light stream comm slash Walsh you
want to pay attention to this li GH TS
TR e a m.com slash Walsh subject to
credit approval rate includes 0.5% auto
pay discount terms and conditions apply
and offers are subject to change without
notice
visit light stream comm slash Walsh for
more information
all right here's something here's here's
something terrible I hate to say but I'm
gonna read now an article from a little
bit of an article from The Daily wire
and says at the very end of February in
elementary school in Arlington Virginia
had kindergarteners sit on the floor to
hear a transgender spokesperson for the
Human Rights Campaign read them a book
in which the claim is made that a boy
can have a girl brain but a boy body or
a boy brain and a girl body the school
district later claimed that quote
parents were notified by a letter ahead
of time and were allowed to opt out as
if they chose but that claim was
reportedly false as kc chalk himself the
father of three small children notes for
the federalists a copy of the February
twenty second letter provided to the
Family Foundation of Virginia under the
Virginia Freedom of Information Act
shows absolutely no offer for parents to
pull their kids out of the activity
moreover although the letter notes that
a book written by a transgender person
will be read to the class it does not
explicitly say that kindergarteners will
be told they may have a girl brain but a
boy body or a boy brain and a girl body
is the book claims nor does it say that
the kids would be read to by a
cross-dressing man who calls himself
Sarah the Washington Post reported that
in February than in the February 28th
class at Ashland elementary school which
was taught by openly homosexual teacher
Jane Foster the transgender advocate
Sarah McBride read the children the
story book I am jazz now ok first of all
this is this is child abuse
plain and simple pure indoctrination
pure brainwashing that and that's what
this that's what that's what that looks
like you know what does it look like for
children to be brainwashed well here it
is it's a bunch of children sitting
around on the carpet listening to a
cross-dressing man reading a book about
transgenderism I mean really this just
this whole scenario which you hear it
and you're horrified by but you're also
not shocked right but this scenario it
sounds like something that a
conservative would have made up
satirically like 10 years ago where
you've got an openly gay kindergarten
teacher inviting a transgender
crossdresser to a kindergarten classroom
to read the kids a story about boys
having girl brains I mean it's just it's
the kind
things like that 10 years ago if you had
if you had made some sort of slippery
slope argument ten years ago and said
you know what where we're headed now
soon enough there's gonna be transgender
cross dressers in kindergarten
classrooms reading stories about
transgenderism to kids if you had said
that everyone would have laughed at you
and said you're crazy that's you know
calm down you're being paranoid
but that's where we are now and so we're
gonna pause here for a moment and and
just analyze that particular point about
girls having boy brains this isn't
really the most important point the most
important point is simply that the
school district and these two men and
everyone else involved are guilty of
abusing these children they are all
agents of ideology they are not
educators they are not fit to educate
but let's let's also examine what they
told these kids in fact if you're
curious at all about the content of this
book that was read to these kids a book
that you can find in the children's
section of many libraries and a book
that well this is this is certainly not
the first time that kids have been read
this book in an elementary school so if
you're interested to know what's in it I
found on YouTube jazz Jennings himself
reading his children's book where he
explains how he discovered that he's a
girl so let me play just a minute or so
of this so that we're all on the same
page no pun intended here it is hello
this is jazz Jennings and I am going to
do a reading of my book I am jazz I am
jazz for as long as I can remember my
favorite color has been pink my second
favorite color is silver and my third
favorite color is green here are some of
my other favorite things dancing singing
backflips drawing soccer swimming makeup
and pretending I'm a pop star most of
all I love mermaids
sometimes I even wear mermaid tail in
the pool
my best friend's are Samantha and Casey
we always have fun together we like high
heels and Princess gowns or cartwheels
and trampolines but I'm not exactly like
Samantha and Casey I have a girl brain
but a boy body this is called
transgender I was born this way when I
was very little and my mom would say
you're such a good boy I would say no
mama good girl
at first my family was confused they'd
always thought of me as a boy as I got a
little older I hardly ever played with
trucks or tools or superheroes only
princesses and mermaid costumes my
brothers told me this was girl stuff I
kept right on playing okay so a number
of significant problems here starting
with the fact that this book and the
transgender theory generally only
reinforces all of the gender stereotypes
that the last has been trying to
demolish for decades so the boys the the
boy didn't like to play with trucks
he liked the color pink he liked dolls
and that means he's a girl you see I
thought that colors and toys and all
that stuff had nothing to do with gender
whatsoever that was the big deal with
remember Target they were gonna stop
segregating their toys by gender and
stop saying well these are the girl toys
these are the boy toys and we were told
that that's a very important thing
because there are no girl toys and there
are no boy toys so if that's the case
then the fact that your boy likes to
play with dolls doesn't mean anything it
is not significant at all how could that
be an indication that your son is really
a girl
if those toys don't mean anything and if
you can't you know delineate between
girl and boy toys it just doesn't make
any sense you're obviously contradicting
yourself so if we are living in this new
enlightened age where we can't even
speak of toys that boys generally like
to play with and toys the girls
generally like to play with then if
that's the case why can't jazz just be a
boy who likes dolls whatever happened to
that category I thought we were told
that there can be boys who like to play
with dolls well well okay fine but now
you're telling us that well not really
because if a boy likes playing with
dolls then he's really a girl the second
point is a child at 2 2 or 3 years old
or however old jazz was saying I'm a
girl
well that means nothing at all because a
three-year-old child has no idea what a
girl is ok so the next time you hear a
three-year-old boy say I'm a girl here's
a good follow up question ask him Oh
what's a girl and what you're gonna
discover is he has no idea he doesn't
know what a girl is he doesn't know what
a boy is because he's 3 you know 3 year
old children will also very frequently
claim to be dinosaurs ninjas princesses
fairies pirates superheroes and so on
they have no idea who they are or what
they are or what's going on in the world
they are living in a fantasy world which
is perfectly healthy and and good and
normal for kids that age but to actually
take their pronouncements seriously when
a three-year-old says I'm a girl or or
you know I'm a dinosaur to action said
well what did you hear that he says he's
a dinosaur lady he says he's a
Stegosaurus you know we better go take
him to the to the Smithsonian and check
I mean what kind of maniac parent does
that do you really not understand the
concept of a three-year-old you're with
your three-year-old every day have you
not noticed that he has no idea what
anything is or what's going on the third
point though is it what is a girl brain
so jazz tells us well
you know I had a I had a girl brain and
a boy body well again I thought that the
left has been telling us for decades
that there is no such thing as a girl
brain in any other context if you were
to speak of girl brains vers boy brains
you would be castigated for that you
would be reprimanded harshly by the left
for saying girl brain so there so what
does that mean you can only have a girl
brain if it's in a boy body but you
can't have girl brains and girl bodies
and also it isn't the brain part of your
body
last I checked it is so what kind of
weird dualism is this where you have
your your your body and then your brain
is some sort of separate organism you
can't speak of well here's my body
here's my brain that's like saying well
I've got my body and then I've got my
left toe you know my it makes no sense
it's part of your body your brain is an
organ in your body like your pancreas or
your spleen or your small intestine if
my brain can magically somehow be a girl
then what about my other organs can I
have a boy body but a girl liver and a
gender questioning you know : I mean how
does this work well that makes
absolutely no sense does it I mean it
wouldn't make any sense at all for me to
say that my lungs are girls but the rest
of my body is a boy exactly it wouldn't
make sense and it doesn't make sense to
say with the brain either remember that
song there was that song that you sang
as a kid about bones all being connected
right the toe bones connected to the
foot bone foot bones connected to ankle
bone so on and so on the point here is
that your body is all connected it's all
one thing there are parts of your body
but that's the point
it's parts of your body it's they're not
completely separate distinct things
they're all they are all part of one
whole it's a synthesis
it's a harmony your brain is connected
to everything else in your body it's
part of your body it's part of the whole
it can't have its own identity in
contrast to the rest of you that makes
no sense
this anti science superstitious
gibberish that's what this is it is it
is superstition and it's being taught in
our schools to our kids meanwhile on a
similar topic also this week reading now
from the Houston Chronicle Houston
public library officials apologized
this past Friday for failing to conduct
a background check on a registered sex
offender who read books to children at
an event hosted by drag queens once
again that is a sentence that ten years
ago if you had predicted something like
this everyone would have said you're
crazy
albert garza a 32 year old registered
sex offender participated in the program
under the name tatyana mala nina library
officials acknowledged in a statement
Friday that Garza has a criminal
background that should have prevented
him from participating in the drag queen
storytime program it was drag queens
read books at the library Department of
Public Safety records show Garza was
convicted of aggravated sexual assault
of an eight-year-old child in 2009 for
which he received five years of
probation and community supervision all
right first of all he sexually assaulted
an eight year old child and he got
probation and supervision he never went
to prison at all are you kidding me
someone who sexually assaults an
eight-year-old child we shouldn't have
to worry about that person showing up at
the libraries you know why because they
should be in prison forever as in that
some
thing where if you do it you should
never be allowed out of your cage ever
again that should be one of those one
strike and you're out kind of situations
but in this in this country it's you
might not be out at all you might not
have to spend any time out of society
out of out of circulation as it were
secondly to those of us who are not
delusional you know it's not terribly
surprising to find out that a guy who
enjoys dressing up like a woman and
prancing about in front of children
might be a sex offender to those of us
who have you know who actually have
brains in our heads whether it's a girl
or boy brain if we have brains at all we
realize that you know that that's sort
of to be expected because it's a weird
to put it mildly it is a weird and
concerning thing to find out that a
grown man enjoys dressing as a woman
number one and in particular dressing as
a woman and then going to a library in
front of children if you find within
yourself the desire as a man to dress up
like a woman and go present yourself to
children that is deeply deeply
concerning and you need to get help you
need to go and I'm not trying to be
funny you need to go and find a
counselor find a therapist and get help
because that is unhealthy and it's and
it's an indication of some serious
things going wrong so this is not
surprising but it shouldn't even
shouldn't even come up because if you're
a library and you want to have an event
where a bunch of children come and they
may listen to a story well that's great
libraries have been doing that for four
decades you know like that's what
libraries should be doing I remember
when I was a kid we would go to the
library sometime and there would be
storytime right okay then just have the
librarian come out and sit there and
read a story why do you need a man
dressed as a woman reading the book why
is that part of it why does that need to
be introduced absolute insanity all
right moving on switching gears here a
little bit there was a study which was
released last week and published in the
Journal of abnormal psychology actually
I guess this is kind of related speaking
of abnormal psychology but this study
says that as we know there's been a
dramatic rise in depression and suicidal
thoughts in young adults over the reason
over recent years and this study says
that social media may be partially to
blame for that
and that isn't much of a revelation
either I think it's undeniable really
that psychologically it's unhealthy to
raise a generation of kids who are
conditioned to live vicariously through
their phones because life is a very big
very dynamic complex beautiful painful
complicated thing and you just can't fit
it inside a phone and that's why you
can't live every day on your phone
because life is just so is beyond that
it's bigger than that but I got to
thinking about why exactly the internet
depresses us so much aside from the
obvious about how you know everyone is
so negative to each other and the lack
of sunlight all that kind of stuff but
what is it really what's what's at the
core of the problem I think it's this I
think that we as human beings are
desperate to make an impact right to
leave an impression to be noticed
to be cared about to be loved and so we
invent this
thing called the internet and we think
okay well here it is now now I can enter
into this world into this cyberspace and
I can interact with millions of other
people and I can really be noticed and
oh look look at all these likes I'm
getting in these shares and these
retweets and comments and everything but
what we find inevitably is that we are
in the end basically dancing and avoid
it doesn't matter what we say here on
the internet nobody will remember nobody
cares
we are just noise it's all a bunch of
noise and we're simply contributing to
it it's all content even if we post a
great hot take on Facebook and it gets
like 52 likes and we think wow 52 people
52 likes that's incredible well those
people were just scrolling through their
feed and you were one of probably about
350 pieces of content that they stumbled
across and they've already forgotten
about all of it they liked your stuff
which they skimmed just as a gesture of
acknowledgment it was just their way of
saying yep I encountered this but it
left no impression on them it made no
difference and thirty seconds later they
forgot what you said so this is the fact
that disturbs us that we spend so much
time on the Internet but we invest so
much of ourselves into this world of the
Internet but we are leaving no mark
there no impression and if we cease to
exist if we disappeared if we died
nobody on the internet would notice or
care or realize that we were gone our
Facebook friends might pause for a
second and go hey whatever happened is
so-and-so but and if we actually do if
we actually did die and they found out
they might leave a little thing that
says our IP on our Facebook page or you
know something like that but then
they'll just go back to scrolling
Instagram and and they'll forget all
about it now I don't exclude myself from
this by the way I have a larger than
average platform on the internet because
I do this
living I do think that writing not
social media post specifically but
actual writing actual long-form real
writing can definitely move people and
have an impact and be remembered and
matter in the grand scheme but it's hard
to write things that matter especially
these days especially on the internet
and most of what I write I fully realize
most of what I write on the internet
most of what anyone writes on the
Internet
won't matter or be remembered I mean I
wrote a viral article about the two
weeks ago I wrote an article about
Michael Jackson about the Michael
Jackson documentary and it got like
600,000 views or something like that
which is a lot 600,000 its 600,000
people read this or about maybe 500,000
people read and and that's that's a lot
of people especially for an editorial
does anyone remember it now if you read
that article do you remember what it
said I don't remember what it said and I
wrote it I wrote I think I wrote in my
opinion if I do say so myself a pretty
good satirical article this past Friday
about the student loan forgiveness idea
and that one did well through got it got
something like 300,000 views this and
this was just a few days ago but does
anyone remember that does it make a
difference what if I went back in time
for days and I stopped myself from
writing that piece would the world look
any different now what anyone's life be
even slightly different what would the
butterfly effect be if that article was
never introduced into reality well there
would be no effect so if I can stockpile
700,000 some Facebook followers and
200,000 some Twitter followers and
hundreds of thousands of readers and all
this stuff if I can do that and still
almost everything I say and share online
including what I'm saying right now he's
forgotten instantly then how much more
must the whole process be defeating for
some seventeen-year-old kid who's trying
to secure an eye
entity for himself here on the Internet
in this place where nobody knows him
nobody cares nobody loves him on the
Internet where we're all just consumers
of and sometimes creators of content and
nothing more
so yeah depressing I would say so it's
it's it's tragic when you consider how
much time we spend here on the internet
not mattering now if you're on the
internet for a couple of minutes a day
and it's really nothing to you then none
of this matters but when this is your
life and you spend hours a day on the
internet trying to be noticed it becomes
very depressing but here's the good news
there are people in your life people
actual real people real life people in
your actual life who you can impact in
profound ways in ways that are deeper
and longer lasting than anything you can
achieve on the internet you know I know
that I'm the most important person in my
wife's life I'm the most important
person on earth to my wife and vice
versa no other person on earth has the
same kind of impact on her that I do I
know that I am right now along with my
wife the most important person in my
children's lives if I died they would be
devastated a hole would be ripped open
in their hearts and it would never ever
be completely filled for as long as they
live that's it how important I am to
them how much they love me and need me
and I them so this is it right here
these are the people along with the rest
of my family and a few close friends I
mean these are the people who who I am
important to the people who will
remember right it's just such a shame
it's such a terrible shame that we spend
so much time trying to be noticed by
people who couldn't care less about us
and who wouldn't be affected one way or
another if we lived or died while at the
same time neglecting the people whose
very existence is partially shaped by
our own existence
the people who we are intertwined with
by blood and and friendship and love and
sacrifice they get the short shrift so
that we can be on the Internet as I was
thinking about this issue I happen to
stumble across another survey that just
makes my point perfectly this was a
survey released this week I think that
finds that young people today are very
stressed out
Millennials are very stress are stressed
about everything and one of the major
stresses for Millennials is number one
cracked phone screens and number two
getting zero likes on a post on social
media is a big time stress in fact 20%
percent of respondents to this survey
said that low engagement on social media
is more stressful to them than getting
into a heated argument with their spouse
and this is exactly what I'm talking
about right that that lack of
recognition from people who don't know
us don't love us don't care about us
creates for many of us a greater void
and becomes a more pressing concern then
even discord and alienation from the
people we love those who are closest to
us and it shouldn't be that way it just
shouldn't so I think that the answer to
a lot of this and the answer to a lot of
the depression and all of us you know
the despair and misery the lie people
feel is just it's really a matter of
we've gotten our priorities just all out
of whack and we're looking for something
in a place where it cannot be found that
is we're looking for impact and
acknowledgement and love and all that
stuff in this world where it's just it's
not on offer there there are things you
can get on the internet there are even
good things you can get information
something you can even get some correct
information every once in a while so
there are things you can find even
entertained
you know even harmless entertainments on
that but those deeper you know human
yearnings cannot be satisfied by the
internet and but they can be satisfied
largely anyway by our real life the
people that are around us and so we have
to look there for all right let's see
what else
quickly wanted to mention this Elizabeth
Warren has come out in favor of
abolishing the electoral college and I
just wanted to mention this because
here's the thing about that first of all
it will never happen abolishing the
electoral college is never gonna happen
ever so it's just an applause line
basically it's not a serious proposal
but taking the idea seriously for just a
moment for the sake of argument I think
we have to admit that it's not a crazy
idea it's not in itself a crazy idea
there is something to be said for it the
electoral college definitely perfect
presents some challenges and we can't
deny that it's not a perfect system by
any means because of the electoral
college
our presidential elections revolve
around a handful of states you've got a
few states that decide everything where
all the presidential candidates go and
the whole election comes down to those
states and if you're in any of the other
states your vote is basically
meaningless especially if if you are
like the situation that I've been in for
most of my life I have been a
conservative in a deep blue state I've
been a conservative in a state that will
never ever go red which means that my
vote in every presidential election the
sense the day I turned 18 has been
completely meaningless because of the
Electoral College now if you had a like
a national popular vote type of system
then theoretically my vote is worth one
vote and everyone's vote is worth one
vote and and you know and so if you have
a hundred and twenty million people
voting or something like that then I am
one out of those hundred twenty million
but with the electoral college system
well all of the electoral votes in my
state are just gonna go the Democrats so
the vote that I sent it's just I just
threw it down a pit it's it doesn't it
it may have some symbolic meaning I can
say well I you know I did my part okay
but see after a while people get tired
of voting symbolically and you really
want to actually vote and have your vote
means something not just mean something
morally but actually mean something and
with the electoral college system in in
many states depending on your politics
it's just the simple fact is it doesn't
mean anything
there really is in the states that I've
lived in there's really been no reason
for me to vote for president I know
everyone says well you got a vote you
got about well why it doesn't matter
doesn't matter you know in my state even
if everyone who agreed with me went to
the polls it still would not matter but
so that's the issue that that and that
is why a lot of people want to get rid
of the Electoral College because they're
just tired of that they're tired of
their vote not meaning anything and that
is a perfectly legitimate problem to to
raise I think but the issue is that well
number one like I said it's not ever
gonna happen anyway
second Democrats only want to change it
because it will benefit them so it's a
bad faith discussion on their part and
they know it it's not about they try to
frame it as well this is you know we
need a pure form of democracy we need to
give everyone a voice so on and so forth
well they only want to give everybody a
voice in that way through some sort of
national popular vote system because
they think probably correctly that if
that were the system you would never see
another Republican president ever again
and that's why they supported and we all
know that so it's a bad faith discussion
but then on the other side I think there
are a lot of Republicans who oppose it
simply because they know that if that
was the system there would never be
another Republican president again
they're opposing it for that reason not
because they actually think that there's
something you know objectively wrong or
unfair with that kind of system but
because they think it well so that's on
both sides that's all it is
and that's the case with so many
discussions that we have these days
where people aren't really worried about
the principle of it they're not worried
about what is objectively the fairest
most logical thing they're just worried
about well what am I going to get out of
this thing all right let's move on
answer a few emails before you wrap up
here Matt wall show at gmail.com Matt
well show at gmail.com is an email this
is from Wes he says thank you for making
the argument that voting rights should
be tied to being a contributing member
of society I have long believed that the
simplest least discriminatory way to do
this would be to restrict voting rights
for those who have a net positive tax
liability on their last 1040 the most
important impact of voting is the manner
in which the government collects and
spends tax revenue so it stands to
reason that only people who should be
who should be should be represented are
the ones actually paying taxes love the
show yeah I think that there's a lot to
be said for that but again that is
something that will never ever happen
but it is nice to think about anyway
this is from Hudson says Matt you
mentioned that the conservative attack
plan on beto is all wrong yes being in a
band has been cool forever his road trip
diaries are easy to laugh at but free
spirits hork that stuff down hork that
stuff down hork that's I never I like
that word I don't know if you made it up
and maybe I'll use it then I read on
daily wire that he was a hacker under
the moniker of psychedelic wizard cut it
out that's badass
don't get me wrong I abhor what the guy
stands for and it kind of seems like a
doofus but come on a bass playing hacker
that's badass
I just wrote to say you're right keep up
the good work I'm a big fan yeah I I
think I mentioned this that you know
attacking beto for being a punk rock
bass playing hacker in the 90s I don't
think that's going to that isn't going
to hurt his cool points it certainly
won't hurt this is from Ken hey Matt I
really liked your show is impressed on
how you address the question of gospel
authorship but my retort to these guys
who might make a too far-reaching claim
about the anonymity of the Gospels is so
what they were written by someone and
form a coherent document that serve as
an Iowa
this account you could mean Jim
Wallace's book cold case Christianity
you get this point if you haven't
already and I would think that the
textual criticism that has been done on
these confirms done on these confirms
that one author wrote each one not a
committee and we know that during the
time the cannon was being gathered as
Scripture the rules were that no
document that was written by someone who
wasn't an eyewitness or did not sit at
the feet of an eyewitness would be part
of the Canon of Scripture anyway good
job of the show keep it up and may the
Lord be with you yeah I think you make
an excellent point there you know I I do
believe that Matthew and John were
written by eyewitnesses but as you say
even if let's say especially John
because John was written you know in the
year 90 AD or later so if it was written
by the the the Apostle John then he was
certainly a very old man at the time but
let's say it was written by his
apprentice or you know someone his
successor who he had passed this
information down to that wouldn't I
wouldn't see that as a terribly
significant problem
finally from Linda says hi Matt I know
I'm Way late on this but I was just
registering I guess listening and that
supposed to say listening to the podcast
you did about about Pascal's wager you
were pretty critical of the argument I
understand your point of view but don't
think but don't you think that the wager
can be helpful just in getting people to
at least stop and consider Christianity
it won't take them all the way but it
will get them on the right road yeah
Linda I am critical of the argument and
no I don't really think I understand
your point but I don't think it's useful
even in the way that you describe
Pascal's wager of course being the
argument that first put forward by
Blaise Pascal that you may as well
believe in God because if you're right
you go to heaven if you're wrong you
don't lose anything but if you don't
believe in God and you're wrong then you
could lose eternity and if you're right
and you don't really gain anything
anyway so then it's sort of like you
might as well believe and that's that's
the argument I really dislike the
argument
as I said before because for one thing
belief just doesn't work that way
belief is not an act of will it's not
something that you simply decide to do
you can't you can't sit here and say I'm
going to believe XYZ you can't do that
you believe something if you think that
the thing is true that's what it means
to believe it if you don't think the
thing is true then you don't believe it
even if you pretend that you do you
don't actually really believe it that's
simply what belief means so for instance
my kids think that there are leprechauns
living in our backyard and they may
think that because I told them I don't
remember exactly but they think that
there are leprechauns living in the
backyard and I I would love to believe
that in fact I really wish there were
leprechauns in the backyard but if there
can't actually be leprechauns then I
would love to believe that there are
leprechauns in the backyard because that
is you know my kids were talking about
my twins or five years old they live in
such a fanciful world where there are
leprechauns and fairies and unicorns and
everything I would love to believe that
also because it's such an exciting world
to live in but I don't believe it
and I can't just say to myself well you
know it would be really nice to believe
that because it would make my life a lot
more exciting so you know what I believe
it doesn't work that way so with God not
that I'm comparing God to leprechauns
but you know you either think that God
exists or you don't if you say God
exists because you want to go to heaven
but you don't really think he does exist
then who are you fooling you're not
fooling God you're probably not even
fooling yourself and you may be fooling
other people but is that is that really
is that it is that is that how you get
to heaven by lying to everybody and
being intellectually dishonest that's my
other problem with Pascal's wager is it
seems to be encouraging intellectual
dishonesty it's saying even if you don't
really believe this just pretend you do
but that's that is intellectual
dishonesty
and I don't think that that's the point
here I don't think that's what God wants
of us but the other problem with the
wager which I didn't mention before and
I'm glad you brought this up because I
was thinking about it it is a it's a
false binary is the other problem what I
mean is that even if someone did buy
that argument and was somehow swayed by
it well there's no reason why it would
lead them directly to Christianity
now yeah Blaise Pascal was a Christian
he's the one who formulated the argument
everyone I've ever heard used the
argument is a Christian so it seems like
the idea is this is an argument that
will lead you torque towards
Christianity but what if somebody buys
the argument and then they decide to
believe that Allah is God or they decide
to believe in Brahma the Hindu god or
they believe in some ancient Aztec god
Pascal's wager even if successful only
gets you to Thea's 'm it doesn't get you
to christianity that's the problem
because in a in in Islam they would also
say that if you are not a Muslim and if
you don't believe in this God Allah you
could be in trouble when when the time
comes so Pascal's wager could apply just
as much to Allah so that's why it turns
out if we want people to accept
Christianity as being true then we need
to give them reasons to think that
Christianity is itself true and if we
can do that if we can successfully
present reasons to believe that
Christianity is true if we can do that
then we don't need Pascal's wager but if
we can't do that then Pascal's wager is
also useless so it seems like it's
useless either way and that's why that's
why I don't like it alright we'll leave
it there thank
everybody for watching thanks for
listening Godspeed